somehow it becomes scarier
when you know that a program generated
code that's running a nuclear power
plant
it becomes scarier you know humans have
errors too
exactly but
it's scarier when a program is doing it
because
why why i mean there's a
there's a fear that a program
like a program may not be
as good as humans to know when stuff is
important to not mess up
like
there's a misalignment of priorities
of values that's potential that maybe
that's the source of the worry
i mean okay if i give you code generated
by
uh
github open pilot and code generated by
a human and say here
use use one of these which which how do
you select today and in the next 10
years which code to use wouldn't you
still be comfortable with the human
at the moment when you go to stanford to
get an mri they will write a bill to the
insurance over twenty thousand dollars
and of this maybe half of that gets paid
by the insurance and the quarter gets
paid by you yeah and the mri cost them
six hundred dollars to make maybe
probably less
and uh what are the values of the person
that writes the software and deploys
this process
it's very difficult for me to say
whether i trust people
i think that what happens there is a
mixture of
um proper anglo-saxon protestant values
where somebody is trying to serve an
abstract greater whole and organized
crime well that's a very harsh you're
i think
that's a harsh view of humanity there's
a lot of bad people whether incompetent
or just malevolent in this world yes
but it feels like the more
malevolent you so the more damage you do
to the world
uh the more resistance you have in your
own
human
like
but don't explain with malevolence or
stupidity what can be explained by just
people acting on their incentives
right so what happens in stanford is not
that somebody is evil
it's just that they do what they're
being paid for
no and this is that's not evil that's i
i tend to so no i see that as
malevolence i see uh
as i
uh even like being a good german as i
told you offline is some it's not
it's not
absolute malevolence but it's a small
amount it's cowardice i mean when you
see there's something wrong with the
world
um it's either incompetence you're not
able to see it
or it's cowardice that you're not able
to stand up not it's not necessarily in
a big way but in a small way
so i
i do think that is in a bit of
malevolence i'm not sure the example
you're describing is the question is
what is it that you are aiming for and
if you don't believe in the future
if you for instance think that the
dollar is going to crash by would you
try to save dollars
if you uh don't think that humanity will
be around in 100 years from now because
uh global warming will wipe out
civilization why would you need to act
as if it were
right so the question is is there an
overarching aesthetics
that is projecting you and the world
into the future which i think is the
basic idea of religion that you
understand the interactions that we have
with each other as some kind of
civilization level agent that is
projecting itself into the future if you
if you don't have that shared purpose
uh right what is there to be ethical for
so i think when we talk about
essex and ai we need to go beyond the
insane bias discussions and so on where
people are just measuring the distance
between a statistic to their uh
preferred um
current world model but the optimism
i was a little confused by the previous
things just to clarify
uh
it's
there is a kind of underlying
morality to
having an optimism that human
civilization will persist for longer
than a hundred years like that like uh i
think a lot of people believe
that it's it's a good thing for us to
keep living yeah of course and thriving
morality itself is not an end to itself
it's instrumental to people living in
100 years from now
right or 500 years from now right so
it's only justifiable if you actually
think that it will lead to people uh or
increase the probability of people being
around in that time frame and a lot of
people don't actually believe that at
least not actively
but i believe what exactly so
most people don't believe that they can
afford to act on such a model
you